I want to ask a
question and it's a it's not a
rhetorical question and it's not a
criticism why do you think it is that
there's a great that the largest per the
largest community of people who have
hurt my feelings at parties over the
years have been uh related to SNL oh is
that true oh yeah okay what is it about
the SNL experience and I'm being very
open-minded about it because it's it
can't be this sort of ad hoc thing where
everyone at SNL is just a little
pathological what goes on at SNL is that
the fraternity that when you do see
someone from SNL at a
party I you know I'm talking first of
all I want to go into a little bit of I
want to do a little bit of forensics
before I proceed uh which is how most
comedians talk
uh make sure you're fully anesthetized
you don't have to name names but you're
talking about performers both and
writers no not not writers as much
performers it's it perform let's just
say performers okay right I don't want
to get too specific and it's not evil
it's not pointedly feels to you it feels
almost reflexive it feels like a
coldness cuz I'm open I show up open and
I show up with the weird expectation
other people are going to meet me there
yeah and there is this sort of pull away
this sort of if it's almost like someone
on SNL has a difficult time pretending
to be interested if they're not does
that does that check out uh I think I
think that's a a couple things uh I mean
it depends I wouldn't make a blanket
statement about like all I don't mean to
I don't want to I'm just saying because
of the people who I've left going I feel
like I
hyperextended and I fell in front of
them or that they walked away and
weren't interested have is that just my
love of SNL uh well possibly I think
there is something in common and and and
maybe it's particular to SNL because
it's you know it's a two-way street here
first of all is this wouldn't happen to
you if you didn't put maybe SNL on a
pedestal so so part of the problem is
maybe you putting uh other people on a
pedestal that's where I've been uh
sometimes hurt before there is a thing
um which is too there's a too cool for
school philosophy that can Thrive at SNL
I've known obviously wonderful great
people there but it is not um one of the
things I think that makes SNL actually
really good uh or has helped it endure
all these years is that there's a
limited amount of real estate to get
stuff on the show and you think about it
it's really dictated by it's a live show
so there's only so much physical real
estate in studio
88 and they can only get so much show on
every week and there is a competition to
get get your sketch on and so at the end
of the day you're competing with other
people in the room now that's just the
way the show is set up
and uh I saw a love a lot of lovely
collaboration when I was there and uh
you can also see a very you know
competitive someone giving you uh
putting their shoulder into yours like
it's hockey and you think Jesus what's
this a lot of things I love about
wintertime M so cold outside you gather
inside with your Chums yeah your Bros
highfive them yeah and you sit around a
crackling fire and you know what you do
what crack open a cold one that's it
isn't it that's it it is it is it is y
and when you crack open a cold one you
better make sure it's Miller Light ah
the best one sit around there's a
roaring fire maybe we just roasted some
chestnuts probably not no one does that
really no then they crack open a Miller
Light and it makes the conversation kind
of flow everyone's happy you guys
talking about sports we are talking
about sports we're talking about hockey
we're talking about highly we're talking
about trucks we're talking about cars
we're talking about things we enjoy and
then every now and then we stop we high
five and we have some more Miller Light
yeah and then it's got that clean finish
oh don't even get me started on the
clean finish and it's only 96 calories
3.2 carbs per 12 ounces again I did
those calculations Mir light Great Taste
96 calories go to miller.com to find out
delivery options near you you don't have
to go to the store delivery options or
you can pick up some miror light pretty
much anywhere they sell beer if you walk
in and they sell beer my guess is
they've got Miller Light celebrate
responsi Miller Brewing Company
Milwaukee Wisconsin 96 calories and 3.2
carbage per 12 ounces SNL is a very
specific
environment uh and I think it's
possible that it there's a kind of maybe
toughness there that it can read does
that make sense you I wondered if it was
because they're so deep in the trenches
together that if you're not someone they
recognize From The Trenches is you can
kind of feel it if like to your point if
they weren't huddled together in ADH
having this experience that is so
bonding with the people who are either
writing for the show weekly or like
friend of show that or I represent
something kind of anti-comedy because
I'm the tall musician guy or something I
can't quite figure it out but I hope
this is more interesting than it feels
like an indictment or me talking it's
not an indictment ofl it's an it's like
this is an experience that you've had
where you felt like you've
encountered Comedians and that's a tough
place that's a that's a that's a that's
not always the most comfortable
terrarium and anyone who worked at SNL
would tell you that um so I would
contrast it say with there are other
shows I've worked on like The Simpsons
where the only way the show gets done is
if everybody works together MH and so
if if this room right now was a Simpsons
Writing Room I'd be praying if we were
stuck on a line for Marge I would be
praying that you came up with it or Matt
or Sona or Edward I'd be like thinking
oh my God someone get it because then we
can go home right and that wasn't always
the way at SNL because it was SNL felt
more like I joined the Marines and it
was really scary and I got yelled at and
I had to do push-ups check out you know
and then but I say that with a huge
caveat cuz I've heard I've talked about
SNL before and I think sometimes it's
been misrepresented I loved that job and
that job changed my life and I learned a
ton there and I wouldn't change a
thing so at the same time so it's both
it's both and mark the out point where
we would edit this because I I don't I
sometimes my curiosity you're making my
job easier
yeah sometimes my curiosity sounds like
this very kind of shrouded criticism of
something but it's really what is it can
I say something else that is I'm on I'm
on Conan's podcast and he asked me if he
could say something
else permission granted I'm sorry I just
remembered you playing buckets of rain
and
I my penis went up inside my
lungs come on which is quite a void by
the way God you had you had a penile
embolism yeah I did my doctor's like
what's this doing in here and my penis
is like there's so much oxygen
this is fantastic oh my God but uh okay
I'm going to tell you I have had the
exact same and I'm I'm not a big
believer in naming names but there are
certain comedians who are my generation
or uh maybe a little older than me just
a little bit but certain comedians that
come from standup specifically who I've
met over the years and they have left me
feeling that way yeah not broken not
destroyed but huh okay I you you know
when you have an interaction with
somebody and you leave and you just have
your body knows before your mind does so
I leave the interaction and I feel like
when you sometimes you bump into and
this is just not talking about famous
people talking to famous people blah
blah blah this is about talking to other
human beings sometimes you bump into
someone and you leave and you feel like
you've been nourished you just have this
nice uh really nice feeling and um you
just feel lifted and I'm the only
mentioning a name right now cuz I just
randomly ran into them the other day but
I saw it was in a restaurant and I'm
walking out and Tom Hanks is there and
anytime I bump into that guy I leave
with this tingly he does something Santa
CLA that makes me feel like you know
that old way of like yeah I he actually
and he gave me a candy
cane which I found creepy by the way uh
he tried to lure me to his
van no but um you know he was there with
Rita and I just I just felt I left and I
felt like it wasn't like a oh my God
that was Tom H cuz I've you know worked
with him and done a bunch of things with
him over the years and interviewed him
it was more just that he was so funny
and he I could see like he saw me as a
person and we had this nice moment and I
left and I he made me feel better and he
does that for everybody he does that for
the person who's changing the a in his
car as if he goes
himself I've seen it I mean I've seen
him do it it's it's a magic know and
people talk about that but he's he's you
know really beautiful that way but these
people I'm talking about these other
people who will go unnamed have just
I've had interactions with them and when
I leave I always feel like they've just
taken just there's like a little bit of
on their finger and they put it on
my for like smeared it on my forehead so
specific yeah and you know what well and
also I realized later on they did do
that con these are very specific people
who put they put their hand their finger
up their ass and then they anoint you
they do it like Ash Wednesday you know
it's true it's like Ash Wednesday but
with you may not be able to play
the guitar like you want to but you are
a born
Lyricist that's why we're gonna write a
song Oh finger Jones is gonna be
all I know is that it's in e um but uh
but
finger have you heard the DECA box set
of
finger oh some of the deep cuts are
fantastic he has a urine phase which is
not good
but I it's acoustic well he went that's
when he went to Austria and had a and
like his Bowie thing it was the 70s he
couldn't get arrested in the states he
ended up in Austria under the Alligator
Records
imprint but all I'm saying is that there
is always by the way real quickly it is
such a great metaphor for someone who
has a great thing going with finger
Jones and then one day goes what about
piss yeah and then everybody goes we
don't like the piss thing we like the
thing we tried we have tapes we can
play for you it didn't work we tried
piss the label the label came to him and
said it's all about piss now yeah when
you put urine on someone they don't
always know that it was urine it's back
feel like sweat yeah it's just it's
going back it's going back it's
regressive and that is Tik Tok but
exactly in a world of I'm being
sold piss but but um there's your lyric
right there just cut me in for
1%
but John but John seriously seriously
like I have that is the exact feeling
I've had with these people and may have
again where there's like a little bit of
a Condes and I feel like I extended
myself and tried to be hey the puppy dog
and then left and I'm driving home and I
just feel a little small a little
deflated a little two dimensional and I
think that's uh that's everybody so
here's what I think it comes down to
certain people are nourishers and
certain people can give energy en and
other people defend their energy and I
think I'm a nourisher I want to I want
to show up with another person who's
going to meet in the middle and we're
going to give give give give give if
you're not that way and I shouldn't
expect everyone to be that way I know
that I'm I'm not rare but it's it's not
everybody who thinks like I think which
is wow how can I give to this experience
how can I like I'm saying looking up to
people who aren't me wanting to give to
people who aren't me other people who
can do that with you it's the greatest
jam out in the world but not everyone
has that other people Survive by way of
preserving what energy they have not
giving it in hopes the other person's
going to give it back and I think that's
the polarity issue right with comics and
we don't have to name anyone it's also
sometimes musicians but musicians are
more of a closed loop in what makes them
happy and where they're validity comes
from their validation comes from so if a
giver is talking to someone who's a
Defender yeah then it that's when The
Giver leaves going but I don't think the
defender leaves going was I a little
cold no I no no they don't they're not
concerned about it and there are people
and I'm again we're not we're talking
about a very specific thing comedy show
business but there just people out in
the world where my best analogy is the
six sense I'm around these people and
before I even see them I can see my
breath suddenly I couldn't see my breath
before but now I can see my breath and
then I turn around and that person is
standing right there you know so let me
ask you this question knowing that if
you can predict that especially with
certain people will you give less
as a self- protection me yeah I will not
only give less but I will also say
Life's too short I don't think I'll go
to that party I think I choose not to
interact with we're all we're talking
about Pat
sck let's put it on the table but I've
learned with certain people I mean he
literally put on my forehead and
you can see it on the wheel theel you
can see it on the wheel it's how they
Mark the wheel it's how you cheat it's
how you cheat wheel forun always he the
there's a little bit of right near
the it's like marking cards yes no
seriously look at Wheel of Fortune
closely you'll see a little bit of
it goes like
this and see John can hear it cuz John
has a musician's ear very it's
very
slish
slish I saw a piece of corn fly off the
wheel once I swear to God and they cut
to say Jack and he was eating corn on
the CP he was and he said Chom Chom we
got a real good show for you today who
the eats corn on the com on
television on television while he's
hosting a game show anyway he'll get his
you'll get yours s
Jack oh man say ja is somewhere
someone's telling him Conan really outed
you on the show for onto your
hand and rubbing it on the wheel or or
he goes out to go to the supermarket and
everyone's yelling at him the cornman
hey cornman he doesn't know why cornman
on the wheel lately or he goes they
found me out yes yes that's what he does
somewhere at St Jack's like no how does
he
know